é vou falar sobre oportunidades
eu queria fazer uma confissão que as
minhas palestras são sempre uma hora e
meia mas quando me disseram que a minha
palestra seria de 18 minutos eu queria
mostrar pra vocês a cara que eu fiz aqui
essa foi a cara que eu fiz quando pensei
em 18 minutos
então eu vou conseguir falar com vocês
só 40 certo nós vamos lá vou falar de
oportunidades quando nasce um filho a
gente tem uma grande oportunidade na
minha filha hoje tem 31 anos e ela foi a
minha grande oportunidade é só que não
foi fácil entender isso como uma
oportunidade
carol nasceu prematuro de sete meses foi
uma incubadora e quando foi compradora a
única oportunidade que eu queria é que
ela sobrevivesse então foram muitos dias
de angústia
onde a gente rezava a noite para que ela
sobrevivesse e de manhã
corria o hospital para saber se ela
tinha sobrevivido e aquele ratinho de 35
centímetros person pesando um quilo de
arroz sobreviveu
era uma lutadora que buscava a sua
oportunidade mas felizes o tempo foi
passando mas de repente a gente percebeu
que tinha alguma coisa errada colocando
menina ela tinha dificuldade para abrir
as mãos era muito estrábica que
dificuldade de coordenação
então a gente ficou muito angustiado com
o que ela apresentava para nós
consultamos alguns médicos e nenhum
tinha o diagnóstico que fosse concreto
vejamos um vôo fomos ao rio de janeiro
fizemos uma tomografia computadorizada
recebemos a notícia carolina é teve uma
nokia
faltou oxigênio no cérebro provavelmente
no parto
então ela ia sofrer as sequelas de uma
paralisia cerebral
ficamos muito assustados e pressionamos
os médicos os médicos para dizer quais
serão as sequelas
elas não quiseram afirmar quais seriam
as sequelas mais humana ela deixou claro
que essa criança dificilmente vai
conseguir andar porque a área afetada
afeta o equilíbrio e coordenação
provavelmente essa criança não vai andar
nós entramos no luto absoluto e não
vimos mais oportunidade para aquela
criança e eu eu entrei no desespero
porque os meus projetos de arquitetura
sempre foram cheios de degraus
eu gostava tanto de grau que até para
chegarem legal é fazer integral ea
carolina não conseguiria entrar nas
minhas obras
então eu preferi rejeitar aquela menina
o pai amava mas o profissional de
arquitetura não conseguia marcar a
menina porque ela destruiu o que tinha
de melhor em mim o que tinha de melhor
em mim é uma área profissional
então ela destruiu o que tinha de melhor
em mim
o tempo passou até que num momento
específico eu descobri que estava errado
e comecei a questionar os meus
paradigmas quem era aquela menina quem
era eu porque ela nasceu na minha vida
porque oportunidades são sempre
questionamentos tão dignas e muitas
vezes a gente não tem coragem de
enfrentar os paradigmas para as
oportunidades porque a gente não quer
quebrar os paradigmas não quer sair da
zona de conforto eu estava na minha zona
de conforto
porém naquela menina e mostrou que havia
12 marius o antes da carolina e depois
da carolina antes da carolina era um
cara que vivia dias a menos
um dia depois do outro
sem entender que cada dia tem que ser
vivido como um dia mais porque cada dia
nós temos que ser melhores que o dia
anterior ea carolina veio pra pra
ensinar que se ela tinha uma limitação
ela veio para me mostrar que a minha
arquitetura podia ser diferente eu
poderia fazer uma arquitetura para todos
ela vem mostrar que eu poderia ser um
pai diferente porque a maioria dos pais
quer fazer dos filhos uma repetição dos
seus paradigmas e os filhos são o novo
os filhos são a nossa renovação e nós
não podemos botar as nossas ações dos
nossos sonhos para que nossos filhos
realize ea carolina vai me provar
exatamente isso
eu tinha que ser um pai diferente eu
tinha que ser um cidadão diferente e ela
e fez nascer como mário depois da
carolina e ela através da educação
ela vai me ensinar diversas coisas como
ser feliz por exemplo com pequenas
coisas porque a felicidade que nós
vivemos hoje é uma felicidade vazia
nós buscamos sempre satisfação e não
entendemos a profundidade ea
simplicidade de ser feliz
queremos comprar coisas ao invés de
sermos coisas ea carolina me ensinou que
ser melhor do que ter
quando nós fomos o levará para estudar o
pré escola
voltamos a belo horizonte acabou não sei
manaus levado pela empresa que
trabalhava e voltamos a belo horizonte
em belo horizonte fomos levar a uma
escola ea única escola que aceitou
vejam só ficava 36 degraus abaixo do
nível da avenida amazonas de novo
escadas na minha vida
todo dia de manhã cedo de cima caiu no
colo botava o mundo na escola
iremos trabalhar por um determinado dia
que uma reunião de pais e professores
levamos a carol de manhã cedo 10 e 6
estudo
sendo assim escadaria de mão dada com a
minha esposa escutamos uma algazarra de
professores jogando de crianças jogando
bola então incluímos que ela tivesse
sentado na cadeira de rodas vendas
criança jogar bola ou então alguém
segurando a embaixo do braço para chutar
a bola chegamos lá ela não estava na
cadeira também não tinha ninguém
carregando ela
olhamos mais traves estava sentado na
trave no chão e na outra trave
uma outra criança sentada no chão a
professora tinha tido o insight que não
transformar carolina igual aos outros a
fazer com que ela fosse ela mesmo dentro
do seu potencial
naquele time as regras do futebol era
que os goleiros jogavam sentados para
que ela não pudesse ser ela mesmo que
ser feliz é a busca de você descobrir
quem você é na realidade e se você é
transformada pelas leis
você não consegue ser completamente
feliz e essa professora começou a
ensinar carolina que era possível ela
ser feliz sendo diferente até porque se
isso é ser diferente é normal e não
existem pessoas normais e pessoas
diferentes somos todos diferentes
portanto somos todos normais e ter uma
deficiência é só uma característica como
ter cabelos louros como ter olhos azuis
e deficiência vocês vão ver daqui a
pouco é muito mais do que só uma
característica carolina se formou no pré
como qualquer outra criança só que
quando vai fazer o primeiro ano nenhuma
escola de belo horizonte aceitou nem
pública nem privada
na época não tinha tal da educação
inclusiva
então ela foi estudar numa escola onde
só tinham crianças com paralisia
cerebral e ali eu descobri que braços
externas audição visão são só e
exclusivamente ferramentas nós não somos
isso aqui
isso aqui são ferramentas que muitas
vezes
nós sub utilizados e essas crianças eram
provocados na escola a ser o máximo que
elas poderiam ser com as ferramentas que
elas tinham ea carolina um aprendeu uma
coisa maravilhosa nessa escola com uma
criança chamada gabriela a gabriela ela
tinha distrofia até os três anos
ela andava e depois por causa da doença
degenerativa parou de andar então a
carolina chegou pra mim e perguntou o
pai que vantagem gabriela teve já tem
andado a lei não entendi a sua pergunta
à filha é pai de gabriela falou que já
andou mas hoje há outra igual eu sendo
empurrada na cadeira de rodas que
vantagem ela já teve já tem andado
eu falei 'não sei' filha eu vou
conseguir responder pergunta para
gabriela ela foi pra escola outro dia ao
invés de voltar com uma pergunta uma
resposta ela voltou com outra pergunta
que me desconcertou o pai possa ser
bailarina profissional numa cadeira de
rodas na huíla não existe para a vida
profissional em cadeira de rodas porque
filha porque a gabriela falou que a
vantagem dela já tem andado naquela
fazia balé lance da doença aparecer e
que ela sonhava em ser bailarina
profissional falei 'não filha esquece
não dá pra ser bailarina profissional
porém ao descobrir que a minha filha
tinha uma coisa do meu dele a teimosia
ela propôs na escola o que fizesse uma
coreografia para apresentar no dia dos
pais
a coreografia chamada felizes que eu não
assisti estava viajando mas uma pessoa
muito especial assistiu a fernanda uma
bailarina do grupo corpo de belo
horizonte que tinham sobre la e ela
achou maravilhoso o que as crianças
fizeram e propôs que fizesse um trabalho
de terapia e dança na escola e que está
gabriela dançando feliz pela primeira
vez com a fernanda ea carolina uma
coreografia solo num palco sendo
aplaudida e ela percebeu que o incentivo
eo aplauso melhorar a autoestima
e com isso melhorar muito a capacidade
ea listagem de busca da carolina ela
aproveitava todas as oportunidades para
fazer o quinto ano nós voltamos pra
joinville
e aqui ela foi estudar em uma escola um
onde ela conviveu com a sua pré
adolescência ea e depois há a abor
recência na quando ela é scheila chegou
aqui a primeira coisa que ela fez foi
querer dançar então convenceu a
professora a montar uma coreografia e
esse e foi crescendo ela conseguiu
coagir as pessoas entram no grupo de
dança e aquela bailarina que eu disse
que não podia dançar dançou durante anos
dos palcos alternativos do festival de
dança de joinville aproveitou todas as
oportunidades clica de um na mão e ela a
cada vez que ela conseguia atingir o
objetivo ela fazia uma atividade radical
rapel rafting band anp patente carolina
realmente me transformou e e aproveitou
todas as oportunidades e buscar os seus
próprios caminhos face ecologia e se
formou aos 23 anos
em seguida já engatou uma pós-graduação
em saúde mental do trabalho já fez uma
segunda faculdade de saúde processos
gerenciais
mas as empresas numa contratava um
porque as empresas queriam cumprir a
cota de pessoas menos qualificadas na
produção pessoas muito qualificadas
recursos humanos que tenham que circular
por empresas que não tinha sensibilidade
não serviu para ela então fez um
concurso público federal e passou hoje é
psicóloga na escola agrícola de araquari
e quando passou no concurso público para
psicólogo escolar
a primeira coisa que ela fez foi uma
pós-graduação em psicopedagogia
então os 26 anos já tinha duas
faculdades e duas pós graduações aquela
menina que inicialmente achava que não
tinha oportunidade única na vida
e ainda foi porta-bandeira de uma escola
de samba e me colocou no ridículo papel
de mestre sala onde eu me sentia que uma
mistura de visconde de sabugosa e
gazelas saltitante mas ela aproveitou a
oportunidade porque a porta bandeira da
príncipes do samba daquele ano que
falava sobre diversidade humana e
pessoas com deficiência
não podia desfilar e foi ofertada pela
oportunidade ela me convenceu então esse
ridículo
bom a carolina ela provou que o homem
voa não porque tem asas mas é porque ela
desejou o vovô a olhou para si e viu que
não tinha asas
era uma grande deficiência mas o desejo
que ser maior do que a deficiência e nós
temos que entender que não só as nossas
capacidades que nos fazem melhor o que
nos fazem crescer o reconhecimento das
nossas deficiências e a decisão de
superá las ea carolina quando foi fazer
o vestibular para psicologia ela pediu
uma coisa pra mim que se ela passasse de
primeira ela queria voar de paraquedas
eu falei 'não filha pelo mundo de deus
chega de inventar esportes radicais
pai eu gostaria muito de volta de
paraquedas mas eu falei pra ela pára
quedas você não vai voar filha é muito
caro eu preciso dos 650 reais pagar a
matrícula e é muito risco
diferente do parapente o pouso para
quedas é o grande problema de disco
então você não volta de paraquedas mas
ela passou no vestibular e uns três anos
depois ela me chamou no quarto dela e me
botou um saco de moedas de r$650 do colo
e falou 'pai eu vou saltar de paraquedas
você sempre me ensinou a superar os meus
limites eu queria terminar mostrando pra
vocês
o salto de paraquedas da carolina mas eu
queria fazer um comparativo entre o
salto de paraquedas ea nossa vida porque
o salto de paraquedas exatamente com
vida nós somos empurrados e nós vamos
ter um momento definitivo do pouso
mas o pouso e pouco interessa o que
interessa
é esse momento em que você faz o vôo e
nós muitas vezes nós perdemos muito
tempo e avaliar esse vôo não valorizamos
cada momento da nossa vida
não valorizamos cada dia nossa vida e
perdendo as oportunidades e elas passam
no brasil uma bica escreveu uma frase no
livro dele dizendo que a maioria das
pessoas hoje morre aos 30 anos e
enterrado às 70 porque aos 30 anos
começa a ganhar dinheiro
acho que estou tendo oportunidades da
vida e com o dinheiro que ganha começa a
colocar coisas que não precisam para ser
felizes e depois que adquiri uma zona de
conforto
faça o resto da vida gastando dinheiro
para manter uma coisa que eles não
precisam nascer feliz
a carolina ela me deu um propósito na
vida e ter um propósito na vida
significa ser proativo naquilo que você
tem de melhor que é o direito de
produzir e nós temos que entender que a
nossa autoestima é construída pelo que
nós produzimos e muitas vezes nós
produzimos gastando o tempo para comprar
coisas e citex é uma forma de produzir
para fazer coisas que é muito melhor do
que ter coisas então queria deixar um
questionamento para que aquela atitude
da vida e eu fico muito feliz em ver que
a média de idade é bem baixa ou seja
jovens estão buscando uma nova forma de
ver o mundo que não seja aquela de
ganhar dinheiro simplesmente mas e
produzir com a sociedade e botar um
questionamento sobre como será o nosso
dia de manhã e se nós teremos a
oportunidade de fazer com que cada dia
seja melhor que o dia anterior porque
nós temos que ser melhor que nós podemos
hoje como disse mário cortella mario
sergio cortella enquanto não podemos ser
melhores ainda amanhã
obrigado por vocês
[Aplausos]